[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24 y
más Romero sala está en nuestro estudio
por supuesto Mara para hablar de los
opioides el día de hoy como lo estábamos
avanzando al principio de esta segunda
hora de programa las nuevas avances que
nos explican mejor como afectan a las
personas que tienen Lamentablemente esta
adicción más buenos días Vamos a hablar
concretamente de un estudio publicado
recientemente por mayo clínica
identifica Como esos caminos dentro de
entre las propias neuronas no que
explican esta adicción o que pueden
ayudar a caracterizar esta adicción Pero
antes vamos a hablar un momento de queso
en los opiellos vamos a dar Un paso
atrás para saber de qué estamos hablando
en general son unas medicaciones legales
unos fármacos legales que se usan para
tratar el dolor no para atenuar el dolor
un ejemplo es la morfina otro muy
conocido es el fentanilo que es un
opioide muy poderosa en este caso el
estudio lo que analiza es la oxicodona
para muchos puede ser algo que mejora su
nivel de vida no o los tratamientos
después de algunos problemas de salud
pero también tiene muchos riesgos en un
uso inadecuado porque son altamente
adictivos no provocan ese bienestar que
adormece el dolor y eso puede terminar
derivando en un consumo inadecuado o
incluso en un trastorno de una adicción
esa desencadenado de hecho una crisis de
salud pública en Estados Unidos también
en otros lugares pero sobre todo en
Estados Unidos y de hecho hay muchas
farmacéuticas que están en procesos
legales por haber recomendado o por
haber vendido indiscriminadamente Y de
forma no responsable este tipo de
fármacos no Vamos a repasar las cifras
un momento según los institutos de salud
pública de Estados Unidos Aquí tenemos
las cifras de muertes por sobredosis en
Estados Unidos a lo largo de los años
vemos como alrededor de los años 2000
estaba sobre los 20.000 muertes anuales
que es mucho pero cómo sigue creciendo
sostenidamente con el tiempo y llegamos
a superar los 90.000 muertes por
sobredosis en 2020 una cifra pues
totalmente alarmante y ahora ya sé que
vamos a entrar a nivel
digamos de este de este problema pero
recordar que es multidimensional social
también relacionado con género con clase
una crisis de salud pública sin duda
bueno como también creo que lo dijo en
su momento del presidente Donald Trump
cuando estaba en su en su administración
volviendo al estudiomar Cómo se
desarrolló Pues básicamente es para ver
cómo reacciona un cerebro tanto a un
opioide que decíamos que era la
oxicodona y también a uno de los
tratamientos que se usan para tratar la
adicción la buprenorfina no Entonces es
una técnica prácticamente de ciencia
ficción en esta Crónica alguna vez
también la hemos hablado lo que hacen lo
que hicieron es tomar muestras de sangre
de tres pacientes con esta adicción
estas se rebobina digamos las células
hasta que sean células madre que se
pueden convertir en cualquier tipo de
tejido y luego esto se convierten en
células neuronales que se van agrupando
hasta formar esos mini cerebros del
tamaño de un guisante en verdad
técnicamente se llaman órganoides no Y
eso pues ayuda a estudiar lo que puede
pasar en el cerebro con una muestra pero
fuera in vitro no todo además es muy
laborioso dura un año tuvimos la
oportunidad de hablar con la doctora
mindhenjo que es la autora principal de
este estudio escuchemosla según
Cuando un paciente viene a la consulta
no nos dan un pedazo de tejido cerebral
Así que cómo estudiamos la depresión o
la adicción
esta tecnología es potencialmente
Revolucionaria en este campo porque
puede eliminar el hueco entre los
estudios preclínicos y clínicos
nos permite desarrollar herramientas de
diagnóstico mejores o entender mejor los
mecanismos moleculares relacionados con
una enfermedad
le preguntó ahora Cuáles han sido los
hallazgos de este estudio claro este
grupo de científicos empezó con una
hipótesis y es que tanto el lopioide
como el tratamiento tendrían un efecto
parecido no en estos mini organismos
Porque al fin y al cabo el segundo
tratamiento se usa para el síndrome de
abstinencia sin embargo una de las cosas
que fueron realmente sorprendentes que
nos decía la doctora Jo también es que
se comportaron de formas totalmente
distintas y que en el caso de lopioide
se observó una inflamación desencadenada
por el sistema inmune así nos lo
explicaba Juan uno de los hallazgos
clave de este estudio se relaciona con
la respuesta inmune
el fármaco que genera adicción despierta
una respuesta inmune excesivamente
activa en los mini cerebros tratados con
el opioides
en cambio eso no se observa con la
buprenorfina Esa es la principal
diferencias en un futuro Qué
implicaciones puede tener Es tomar pues
es uno de los estudios que dejan más
preguntas que respuestas no que abren
unos caminos no es una gran conclusión
que tenga un redoble de tambores Pero va
a ser indispe y de hecho también la
doctora fue apuntaba a algunos posibles
futuros
este estudio observa los mecanismos
moleculares a nivel celular
el siguiente paso podría ser hacer
pruebas a nivel funcional de varios
fármacos que se dirijan a este camino
relacionado con la adicción a los
opioides hay muchas otras vías de
investigación
Sí entonces Raúl probablemente en unos
años estaremos dando un nuevo hallazgo
que hubiera sido indispensable sin que
ellos Hubieran hecho este mapa de las
reacciones al cerebro a los opioides Así
es el mar Muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de salud
mañana jueves con más mañana
[Música]